[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who thought we wouldn't get
any thor pictures but we've got them
we've got them in
and the puns are even worse than ever
now this video we're just going to be
breaking them all down but if this is
your first time here then make sure you
subscribe to the channel
as we do videos like this every day and
we're also giving away some cool prizes
to people just like you that i'll tell
you more about at the end of the video
now up top i have to say how excited i
am for this movie as
i absolutely love taika with his work on
thor ragnarok and think he's just the
perfect person to take the character
in lots of crazy different directions
filming for the upcoming movie has been
going on for some time but everything's
been kept under wraps and it's only
today that we've got our first look at
the film
the blockbuster is currently being
filmed in australia and it's actually
part of the federal government's 24.1
million
location incentive grant judo covered in
everything that's going on it is kind of
difficult to get sets rolling so i'm
really happy that they've managed to get
things in place
and really go forward with this as it's
going to be something special
now avengers end game of course ended up
with thor going off with the guardians
of the galaxy
and it looks like they're back here as
both chris hemsworth and chris pratt
were spotted on set
at the centennial park on monday the
costumes have had some upgrades
and though is seen rocking a sleeveless
red leather jacket and some amazing
denim pants
he's got the braids back he's trimmed
his beard up he's not looking as out of
shape as he was in avengers end game
and yeah the guy's back and ready to
bust heads as for star lord he's got a
lot more plating on his jacket
and it really looks like they're they're
taking these characters in a new
direction
now something interesting that i haven't
seen many people point out
is that thor is actually holding
stormbreaker which will probably be
making its return
as his main weapon however i do kind of
think that bait array bill may show up
at some point in the film
and that he will give him that and keep
the hammer for himself
however that does kind of open up what's
gonna happen with natalie portman's
character
as we do know from comic con that she
will actually be becoming thor in this
movie
and it'll be a sort of passing of the
hammer to her
whether that means that thor doesn't
have any weapons at all or like i said
he gives stormbreaker the bait-rate bill
or just keeps it for himself we don't
know but yeah
it's just kind of my first reaction to
these images and i'm really excited for
the movie
another interesting thing about the
first look is because the dreads have
been changed back to the braids
we can see that single one that we know
from the mcu has
a bit of loki's hair threaded through it
loki of course died in infinity war
but then in avengers end game they
created a branch reality in which he
spun off into disney plus we don't know
exactly what's gonna happen with that
show or how it's gonna be brought across
but i personally think that at the end
of it he'll be uh [ __ ] back into the
main timeline
and thor will be like oh man i thought i
lost you but you're back
great impressions as always but this
braiding does kind of
show that he still holds the character
very dear to his heart
and i think it would be amazing for for
him to lose his brother and then get
reunited with him
throughout endgame a lot of his
depression stemmed from the fact that he
not only lost his father
his mother half his people his home and
his brother
but also the fact that he he basically
he was the reason that half of all life
in the universe got wiped out
so he's won that he's finally shed the
thing from his shoulders that
was getting him down he's back in shape
and this braid sort of
signifies to me that his brother he
could return
i really hope he does but of course we
will find out now that i haven't talked
about this film in depth we do know that
matt damon who cameoed in the ragnarok
will be returning for this film but
whether he's a different character or
not we don't know yet
personally i think they might make him
into a cgi creation or something
i'd love to see him as bait or a bill or
you know they could just keep him
as the actor that he appeared as now why
that situation is possible is because
sam neil has also admitted that there's
a good chance he's gonna appear in it
too
and we don't know what's being set in
stone or not neil did say that the main
problem was traveling between new
zealand and australia which was
problematic for him at the moment
but they were trying to work things out
so fingers crossed they get something in
place that
is more than just a cameo now obviously
i'd love to hear your thoughts on these
first looks whether you think the suit
looks great or not
personally i absolutely love it and i
think they they've done an amazing job
of kind of tying thor's colors into this
brand new costume
that looks very funky taikuiti of course
has as his own style and
really brings a lot of flair to the
character and i think this is just a
great way to take him
going forward obviously he's not going
to be wearing this forever but
you know it's nice to just see them
change it up once in a while
now as mentioned earlier we are doing a
giveaway on the channel and at the end
of the month three of you will be
winning a copy of the marvel phase three
box set
completely free all you have to do is be
subscribed to the channel
make sure you comment on the videos
throughout the month and then i'm gonna
pick them at random and then ship the
sets out to you
the winners of our last month's
competition are on screen now so if
that's you
then make sure you make sure you message
me on twitter and i'll get that over to
you
now if you want something else to watch
make sure you check out our breakdown of
one division episode four which will be
linked on screen right now
a lot more in depth in this video is uh
we're just going over all the easter
eggs
things you missed and giving our
theories for the show so definitely
check it out after this if you want
something else to watch
without the way thank you for clicking
this i've been paul you've been the best
i'll see you next time take care peace